[Musique]
le quartier de corbeil ville c'est un
quartier qui sur le plateau et qui a une
relation avec la vallée assez difficiles
sur lesquels il ya un domaine de château
qui étaient toujours pris par thales le
but c'est l'objectif c'est de faire un
quartier très résidentiel où il y aura
surtout dans la partie est
mais aussi avec
activités économiques sur l'ouest et ce
qui est important pour nous c'est que ce
quartier face un trait d'union non
seulement est restée qui crée un vrai
lien physique avec le quartier des
moulins et celui de l'école des bouts de
technique mais avant tout aussi un lien
me reçut deux c'est-à-dire plateau et
vallées notre objectif c'est décrit en
quartiers au sein du plateau de saclay
mais c'est aussi un quartier de la ville
d'orsay
les gens sont préoccupés parce qu'il ya
plus de monde qui va venir il faut
circuler va y avoir un hôpital il va y
avoir des équipements
du coup il faut que ce soit fluide on
fait pas des champs à travers leurs
quartiers là où ils habitent et ils sont
aussi préoccupés parce que qu'est-ce que
c'est un vrai lien plateau au valais
puisque c'est assez difficile
je pense que c'est important de les
écouter mais de toute façon là en fait
leur marque sont très pertinents moi
j'étais aussi ravi d'entendre qu'ils
souhaitent et qui sont contents qu'on
peut restaurer le domaine de château et
qu'ils veulent un endroit qui rappelle
l'histoire de ce site et je trouve que
c'est une histoire dont je connaissais
pas tout et puis je découvre aussi qu'il
connaît super bien le lieu où ils
habitent et les environnements c'est par
la vie quotidienne qu'on peut comprendre
qu'ils doivent être les usages du
sauveteur que retient on entend les
considérations qu'ils ont qu'est ce que
c'est un commerce qu'est ce que c'est un
quartier avec une centralité qu'est ce
que ça veut dire qu'ils veulent que ça
reste humaine
ça reste à petite échelle voilà et je
pense que c'est important de le savoir
mais c'est assez proche de notre vision
ce qu'on a sur ce quartier qu'on veut
instaurer
[Musique]